Hey guys! Welcome back to another day
experimenting with hot vs cold.
Now for months and months now,
even before I was playing with liquid nitrogen and gasoline,
I've had hundreds and hundreds of people asking me
to mix gasoline with dry ice,
to light dry ice on fire,
and to drop dry ice into burning gasoline.
So today we're going to be trying all three of those experiments
just to observe what happens.
So today I picked a comment by Bonnie In The Box who  says "gasoline vs dry ice...make it happen!"
So we're doing this for you, Bonnie,
and for everyone else who suggested the same thing.
Okay, disclaimer
Gasoline is a very volatile substance
and can lead to a fire that gets out of control very, very quickly
recommend trying at home because if
something goes terribly wrong you may no
longer have a home all right for our
first experiment let's try drilling a
hole into a block of ice then using some
gasoline to fill up that hole and
observe how the two materials react
Ooh, look at that! We ended up making dry ice snow.
So I just used a Forstner bit to
drill a hole right in the center of this
block of dry ice and it runs about 3/4
to 1 inch deep and over here I filled up
a measuring cup with 91 octane let's go
ahead and pour it in and see what
happens this is actually a little more
than I'm comfortable working with and we
pour some that out I'm going to start
off just putting a couple of small drops
in there
make the little humanoid
I blow the vapor away you can actually
see the liquid gas flame in there
irrelevant one
I wonder if the dryest can freeze it you
know ghastly and I believe starts to
freeze around 40 degrees Fahrenheit and
the driest is around minus 109 settles
down mostly quickly
still seems pretty liquidy
all right so gasoline in dry ice doesn't
really seem to do much just kind of
sitting there chilling I'm sure it's
getting colder but I don't see any
reaction with the carbon dioxide so
while we've got this cooling over here
I'm going to flip things over the other
way which is a lot of small piece of dry
ice and drop it into a glass full of gas
I've got a small piece of dry ice here
it's about the size of a quarter I'm
very comfortable working with that let's
drop it in see what happens contact
through a bitter soil
Oh God I keep thinking until that out of
the glass and it settles down
now what's happening here is the
gasoline is warming up the block of
drives and the dryest is sublimating and
releasing carbon oxide gas which means
we effectively have a barrier of carbon
dioxide right here which makes me wonder
if we lit up a match and tried to light
the gasoline at this point with the
carbon dioxide put the match out or with
the gasoline thrown off we might have to
dry
someone's truth
oh you got a barrier that prevents the
gasoline from being lit without oxygen
our gasoline can't burn and now we've
got a protective layer preventing any
open flames getting down to it
interesting now thinking about this
let's try taking it to the next level do
you think we can actually use gasoline
to put out a match if we had a flaming
match and dump it down into liquid we do
it in such a way that the match goes out
and nothing catches fire I think if we
have a small barrier of carbon dioxide
on the top to prevent any oxygen from
getting in it just might be possible so
our driest is just starting to settle
down which means we should have a nice
layer of carbon dioxide in here so if we
strike a match theoretically we should
be able to drop it down in liquid and
have gasoline put the match out maybe
it'll work alright here we go
gasoline versus match in three two one
drop and it goes out that is beautiful
that is a beautiful thing we just use
gasoline to put out a fire at the mind
blow this really is gasoline guys and to
prove that we can blow off the carbon
dioxide layer and touch it off with a
match and it should light off it's like
that so you can see that by dipping our
match very quickly through a small layer
of carbon dioxide into the gas the
gasoline actually puts the match out now
to put out a gas fire like this we can
just take a damp rag very carefully
placed over top for one to two seconds
and just like magic it's gone out
alright so back to our gasoline in the
dry it's been sitting here for about 15
minutes and I can see the top layer is
starting to crust over a little bit so
it looks like over time our gasoline
will actually freeze but it takes an
extremely long time to do that since
we're still waiting for that I'm going
to drill a small hole in the block and
dry it so let up with a little bit more
gasoline and
that one
just going to take that snow and dump it
over here gasps give that's keeping the
reaction at all
cool let's light that off all right here
we go
oh I can't get life well let me blow out
some of that carbon dioxide layer first
I can work faster to update guys I've
tried about eight times and I cannot get
the gasoline in this small hole dries to
light off
let's chisel the frozen gasoline out of
the center hole fill it up and keep a
bigger hole makes a difference this
stuff right here is frozen gasoline we
know what that does right see
I'm not even that late gasoline versus
dry ice dry ass win all right that
spilled up completely to the top let's
go ahead and light it off with hot three
two one and it goes out every single
time it goes out I cannot get this stuff
to light off it's crazy
even if I blow off the carbon dioxide
vapor first the match still goes out I
cannot get gas when you light off and
drive alright guys so even with big
healthy flames so far I'm having zero
success letting gasoline and dry eyes
you can see little bits of gasoline
spurting up in the igniting once we get
it down to the liquid itself goes out
every time we know that this is because
the carbon dioxide is acting as a
barrier preventing any oxygen from
getting the gasoline and the liquid
gasoline itself isn't plowable so we can
state a mess right down inside it that
goes right out so the only way to get
any kind of flaming effect I think it's
the light a container of gasoline on
fire first and then throw some chunks of
dry ice into it next and this could get
extremely dangerous so for this last
experiment we're going outside all right
let's light it up
goes off no problem alright one chunk of
dry ice what's it going to do
it bubbles and spatters and she's guess
what
throw in a bigger chunk
oh wow we're gonna spread
I wonder if we threw a few tungsten
drives down into the plain old house
that's a lot of gas you know what's
going to happen is that clap is going to
break and gas thing is going to go
everywhere so look at the dry ice it's
starting to put out the flame it's on
fire but the flame can't keep up because
the dry ice and the carbon dioxide
putting it out I'm gonna go get some
more dry
look at the cup the cup actually went
out the flame went out
oh my gosh that's so cool so fire versus
dry ice dry ice win that was incredible
that was a fire that was starting to get
out of control and the dry ice just took
me down and now watch this if I try
lighting off another match and igniting
the gasoline it won't go off the match
just goes right out is that it actually
put out the flame
even on the ground if you that keep on
the ground the flame way out can't get
this cup to go off the gasoline down
here can even get that to light off the
matches just go out what about a whole
bundle of matches you all just go out
that is cool that is cool
oh I like that
that slowly starts bubbling and spitting
and now look because it's a bigger
container it's producing carbon dioxide
inside the container and the flames are
having a hard time keeping up
to another face
or claim just went out so on the large
bowl by putting chumps and rice in there
very carefully it actually suppress the
flame and made it go out and at this
point I can't light it off I'm
relatively comfortable standing right
over top of it with an open match right
now and trying to light it because
nothing happens it just goes right out
so a lot of really interesting things
learned here today we start off this
experiment by pouring gasoline into a
hole that we made in a chunk of dry ice
now after the initial shock of the two
temperatures meeting the gasoline
settled down and nothing more really
seemed to happen so we set that to the
side for a minute and we flipped the
experiment by dropping small chunks of
dry ice into a cup full of gasoline to
see if we could produce any different
result we saw that the reaction of the
dry sublimating inside the gasoline
caused the gas to bubble up in foam at
the top and in some cases even spill
over the edge we also discovered that
the gasoline was covered by a thin
coating of carbon dioxide gas which
would prevent an open flame from
lighting it off so we tried an
experiment to see if we could use
gasoline to actually put out a fire and
it worked every time we went back to our
block of dry ice drilled a bigger hole
and tried to light off the gas with
absolutely no success so for our final
experiment we went outside with a
container of gasoline lit it on fire
first and dropped in chunks of drives
after in the first container the dryest
made the gasoline spew out into the open
air where it quickly accelerated into an
uncontrollable flame we tried taking
chunks of dry and setting them down into
the flame and in less than a minute our
gas fire has been completely smothered
but in the second round we used a larger
bowl with more surface area and slowly
slip the drive inside but even though
the liquid is burning with a healthy
flame as the carbon dioxide rose from
below it smothered the flame and put the
fire out so in conclusion I think that
we've seen when it comes to fire versus
dry ice dry
and a big thanks to Bonnie in the box
for leaving the suggestion in the
comments you can go ahead and check your
youtube inbox Bonnie I'm sending 25
bucks well that's it for this experiment
guys thanks for joining me and I'll be
looking for you in the next video
talk to you then
yikes don't really want that stuff
spilling everywhere I'm not going to be
good for the general health and safety
many people who live here even our
improvised name